America's got that but leaked audio from
80 internal Tick Tock meetings shows
that U.S user data has been repeatedly
accessed from China when you said it
hasn't been and here's the other thing
following back on my my colleague's line
of questioning in your own privacy
policy it says that you may even share
information within your so-called
corporate group is bystands part of that
corporate group if you're talking about
this the share of the The Entity with
the with the share I like I shared with
uh the previous um this bite Dance part
of the corporate group
by dance as a holding company is part of
the corporate group yes it's part of the
grouper group okay so your own privacy
policy says you have to share data with
bite dance and if the CCP says Hey bite
dance you're going to do what we say and
you can't tell anyone about it because
by law according to that 2017 uh
National Intelligence law they have to
do it that's our concern maybe you
haven't done it yet but my point is that
you might have to and that's where our
concerns come from I mean over over 300
Tick-Tock employees have worked for
China's state-run propaganda media
that's just from looking at their
LinkedIn profiles okay so here and my
last point is this I want to say this to
all the teenagers out there and then
Tick Tock influencers who think we're
just old and out of touch and don't know
what we're talking about trying to take
away your favorite app you may not care
that your data is being accessed now but
it will be one day when you do care
about it and here's the real problem
with data comes power they can choose
what you see and how you see it they can
make you believe things that are not
true they can encourage you to engage in
behavior that will destroy your life
even if it is not happening yet it could
in the future the long-term goal of the
Chinese Communist party is the demise of
the American power and that starts with
our youth at any moment they could
demand that all of tick tock's data be
used to design an AI algorithm with the
sole purpose of promoting Chinese
interests and destroying our society
from within you want to know why that's
Democrat why that's why Democrats and
Republicans have come together on this
that's why we are so concerned thank you
and I yield back this is The Tick Tock
CEO show Z2 getting grilled by a
congressman on whether or not Tick Tock
is controlled by the Chinese Communist
party and The Tick Tock CEO's answers
are lack of answers were very revealing
about how how much power the CCP
actually has over Tick Tock and it
started out with the tick tock CEO
pretending that he doesn't know that a
bunch of bite dance employees are
hardcore Chinese Communist party members
many of the workers who work at bite
dancer Communist party members right
I I wouldn't know this dude is outright
lying right here because as the CEO of
tick tock he obviously knows about the
investigation by force back in 2022 that
exposed a close relationship between
hundreds of bite dance and Tick Tock
employees with China's literal
propaganda industry
300 current employees at Tick Tock and
its parent company bite dance previously
worked for Chinese State media
Publications and Forbes didn't even have
to do any hard digging to find this
Intel because it was on their Public
Employee LinkedIn profiles 23 of these
profiles appear to have been created by
current by dance directors who managed
Apartments overseeing content
Partnerships public affairs Corporate
social responsibility and media
cooperation whatever that means 15 of
those LinkedIn profiles indicate that
current bidance employees are also
concurrently employed by Chinese State
media entities including xinhua news
agency China Radio International and
China central China global television
these are the same news organizations
that do things like repeatedly denied
China's genocide of the uighur Muslim
minority calling the report's fabricated
false information like what the xinhua
news agency did which forced found 39
profiles of current Tick-Tock and by
dance employees that previously bought
the xinhua including a Content strategy
manager who was formerly a chief
correspondent for xinhua news after the
story broke tiktok and bytes didn't even
deny these connections to Chinese State
media nor did the Chinese State media
Outlets deny the connections to bite
dance and Tick Tock but bite Dance's
connection to the CCP gets even deeper
one LinkedIn profile representing a
current Tick-Tock feature strategy lead
says that that person previously worked
for the China internet information
center or china.org.cn a state-run web
portal whose editor-in-chief is also a
party secretary and former deputy head
of propaganda for the Chinese Communist
Party
during The Tick Tock employees time
there his Department published headlines
like safeguarding she's core position is
the key communique or under she's watch
China's Sunshine Island bask and warmth
of opening up and she stresses
importance of the Communist Manifesto
ah yes this is the perfect guy to decide
what Tick Tock features to give the
American public next as tiktok's feature
strategy lead another employee Now by
dances Vice general manager of media
Partnerships previously ran social media
for china.org CN among the portal social
media posts during his tenure were
Facebook post how to why China Niche Xi
Jinping as his core leader and human
right type isn't good for the US or
China
but the most damning evidence of them
all is how bite Dance's Chief editor
Jung Fu ping is also by Dance's official
Communist Party secretary what you have
to understand about business in China is
that lots of businesses in China are
required to have an internal CCP
committee and Jung Fu ping is the leader
of the one at bite dance and what is the
purpose of an internal CCP committee
within the company well according to
article 33 of the Constitution of the
Communist Party of China is the mixture
of private companies implement the
party's principles and policies so bite
dances internal CCP committee is there
to literally implement the ccp's agenda
and according to bydance's party
secretary's profile he confirms that
saying that his mission at bite dance is
to transmit the correct political
Direction public opinion guidance and
value orientation into every business
and product line
so for the tick tock CEO to deny by
Dance's connection with the CCP is
psychotic which is why he later walks
back on a statement do you know of any
other employees that work for bite dance
that are part of the Chinese Communist
party like I said you know they are by
dance has owns Chinese businesses and
they operate in China you don't know how
many but you acknowledge many must be
card carrying members of the CCP right
in the Chinese business yeah yeah but
that doesn't matter that's bite dance
for tick tock we are American we're not
controlled by China at all we're out of
reach what is that really true
[Music]
or really fast if you happen to ship
stuff online and you're looking to save
more time and money with shipping then
you have to check out shipstation
shipstation is hands down the best way
to ship because it lets you save up to
84 from Top carriers like UPS USPS and
DHL Express while letting you streamline
everything it lets you integrate what
all the major selling channels out there
it helps you keep track of all the
logistics that come with shipping and
managing inventory you can even add your
own custom branding with custom packing
slip templates branded tracking Pages
brand new returns portals and more and
you'll even get free comprehensive
onboarding support to get you shipping
faster right away that is why over 130
000 Merchants use ship station and why
98 of companies that use shipstation for
a year end up using it for life and you
can get started by going to
shipstation.com for a 60-day free trial
that's two months of Cheaper simpler
shipping completely for free go to
shiftstation.com with the link below to
sign up right now thanks to shipstation
for sponsoring this video foreign
[Music]
really hard to separate Tick Tock from
China especially with their project
Texas thing that the CEO kept bringing
up data is stored here in American soil
is to move the data in into the United
States project Texas was tiktok's grand
plan to relocate all U.S user data to
U.S servers in Texas that are owned and
operated by Oracle an independent U.S
company the idea was to make it look
like Tick Tock just can't hand over data
to China but that is just simply not
true as Tick Tock has shown Us in the
past in 2022 BuzzFeed published a
damning article about how leaked audio
from 80 internal Tick Tock memos shows
that American data has been repeatedly
accessed from China by Chinese employees
the recordings which were reviewed by
BuzzFeed news contained 14 statements
from nine different Tick Tock employees
indicating that engineers in China had
access to U.S data everything is seen in
China said a member of tiktok's trust
and safety department in another
September meeting a director referred to
one beijing-based engineer as a master
admin who has access to everything which
is not all that surprising when you
learn that tick tock's own privacy
policy since it can share data with by
dance as his parent company quote we may
share your information with other
members considerators or Affiliates of
our corporate group to provide the
platform including improving and
optimizing the platform preventing
illegal use and supporting users in your
own privacy policy it says that you may
even share information within your
so-called corporate group is bypass part
of that corporate group if you're
talking about this the share of the The
Entity with the with the share I like I
shared with the previous um this bite
Dance part of the corporate group
by dance as a holding company is part of
the corporate group yes it's part of the
girlfriend group okay so your own
privacy policy says you have to share
data with bite dance and if the CCP says
Hey bite dance you're going to do what
we say and you can't tell anyone about
it because by law according to that 2017
uh National Intelligence law they have
to do it that's our concern maybe you
haven't done it yet but my point is that
you might have to but according to the
tick tock CEO all these connections with
the CCP have nothing to do with Tick
Tock I mean the CCP holds a what's
called a golden share invite dance that
allows the CCP to control one board seat
invite dance that's public that's not
correct it's not correct it's been
publicly reported they admitted to it is
you can on our website we have updated
it so we have can give people more
transparent information on this they
have us share in a subsidiary that is
only for the Chinese business it has
nothing to do with Tick Tock and it's
for the purposes of content Licensing in
China it's just happening in the Chinese
version of tech talk do Yen which by
dance also owns according to the tick
tock CEO that's where the CCP gets its
golden share from and bought a one
percent Sharon dunion and that's it and
choose opinion that one percent share
has nothing to do with Tick Tock and how
it's run but researchers have already
found that the leadership in dunyan and
Tick Tock overlast with bite dance as
their parent company but the final nail
in the coffin that destroys the tiktok
CEO's argument is China's 2017 National
Intelligence law this sweeping Law
requires all Chinese organizations like
white dance and every single Chinese
citizen like the one white dance employs
and can access American data all of them
everyone in China is required to support
assist and cooperate with National
Intelligence efforts and to keep secret
the state intelligence work that they
know translated from legal speak
everyone in China including companies
are required to spy on the behalf of the
CCP if they get asked to so even though
Tick Tock is a foreign subsidiary of
bite dance its employees in China could
still be required to access the data and
share it with the CCP because the
National Intelligence law also applies
globally to Chinese groups whereby all
subsidiaries even those outside of China
could be subject to the law and because
anyone who spies for the CCP has to keep
it a secret even if bite dance or
Chinese Tick Tock employees did spy on
Americans The Tick Tock CEO wouldn't
even know about it because they wouldn't
be able to tell him so it's no wonder
why a leaked memo as Tick Tock employees
to downplay the parent company by dance
and to downplay the China Association
it's no wonder why bite dance has
instructed its Tick Tock moderators in
the past to censor videos that mention
Tiananmen Square Tibetan Independence or
the Hong Kong protests and it's no
wonder why Revelations like this will
probably keep popping up in the future
is because no matter how hard they try
Tick Tock is as Chinese as they come
and the reason why the Chinese
government loves Tick Tock so much is
because Tick Tock is the perfect weapon
for the 21st century Battleground
they're afraid it's going to look like
World War II they're afraid it's going
to look like nuclear weapons blowing up
in major cities that's War and the idea
of conflict evolves
the reason World War II looked nothing
like World War One and the reason World
War One didn't look anything like
revolutions before that is because
conflict grows just like people grow
why would we expect World War III
to look anything like World War II
it doesn't make any sense in America we
think in terms of the next quarter the
next earnings report the next year the
next 10 years maybe but China they think
in terms of decades and the best way to
destroy an Empire over time without
going to war is from within and the best
way to corrupt it from within is to
corrupt its youth because kids are the
future and tiktok has become the best
weapon for corrupting the youth kids
spend 99 minutes on Tick Tock every
single day that's over an hour and a
half of conditioning every day most
parents don't even talk to their kids
for over an hour and a half every day
and during this hour and a half
America's youth are being fed a bunch of
dumb stuff and basically soft porn and
what was that thing Saladin had to say
about this the famous Muslim Sultan that
ruled over Egypt to Arabia oh yeah he
once said that if you want to destroy
Any Nation without War make adultery or
nudity common in the Young Generation
and tiktok is playing a major role in
nuts
[Music]
but regardless of how bad tick tock is
the bill that was introduced to ban the
app is absolutely terrifying it's called
the restrict act and it gives the
government the ability to go after
anyone they deem a national security
risk at which point they can access
everything from their computer to video
games to their ring light the bill to
bend Tick Tock is a trojan horse a
trojan horse to hide the fact that it is
a modern day Patriot Act for the
internet
[Music]
thank you